if you were thinking of starting
coinbase today would you do it as a
centralized or as a decentralized type
effort right
i'm assuming at some point this has kind
of come up whether it's due to
regulatory stuff whether it's due to
remote work or whatever but how do you
evaluate like centralization versus
decentralization around coinbase itself
and maybe even like could you
decentralize the company in the future
or how do you think about all that yeah
that's the funny question if i was
creating today i mean so i would
definitely go remote first um
i would definitely
i think i would lean more into some
decentralization aspects in the sense
that like we'd probably just put a lot
of our documentation we have internally
i just make it all public and just do it
out in the open i think it's like good
marketing it's good transparency
we might even be like hire pseudonymous
people you know what i do it as a dao so
i think the dao the dow tools need to
still get a little bit refined um in the
sense that i think you should have a dao
is probably like the governing body of
these organizations but
in local countries where you operate you
may actually still need a c-corp that's
like controlled by the dao
um
there's a company called research hub
which i'm helping get off the ground and
it's it's creating an online community
like github for science it's trying to
help accelerate science and make it more
like open source software and with that
structure we actually did go and create
a dao
and a c corp and it's been like a very
interesting um process for me to figure
out
what that the future of the corporation
is going to look like in that world and
so i'm sort of beta testing it there
trying to iron out a lot of the details
what's super frustrating is like there's
no well paved road so you have to spend
more with the lawyers and they don't
they can't give you any kind of clear
answer they're like well no one's done
it before so try this that seems like a
reasonable thing and we'll see how it
goes so i think my hope is that by
learning from some of those experiments
like with research hub we can then go
and productize this at coinbase and make
it easy for anybody to create that
future type of entity in just like a you
know simple interface you don't have to
spend tens of thousand dollars tens of
thousands of dollars with lawyers
um but i yeah that's the direction i
would had for sure if i were creating a
company today yeah it is absolutely
fascinating to think about how quickly
all this has moved since you started
coinbase to where we are today you know
everything from nation states adopting
bitcoin to uh talking about you know
tangible things around daos and nfts and
and all of that and then obviously in
the next you know five ten years uh
it'll be pretty incredible to see
everything else that gets created
where can we send people if they're
interested in
working at coinbase following you on the
internet or just kind of learning more
about what you and the rest of the team
are doing
yeah well um coinbase is a great place
to start a crypto career if you're
trying to learn more about crypto or you
want to eventually even want to start a
company i think we're a good place for
that you can check out coinbase.com
careers
you can follow us on on twitter
obviously at coinbase or uh myself at
brian underscore armstrong
um so thanks for yeah following us along
and hopefully we can all keep building
the crypto economy together absolutely
well listen thank you so much for taking
the time to do this i know you got a
million things going on hopefully
everyone enjoyed this and we'll
definitely have to do it again in the
future
yeah that was great thanks for the
questions and the interview that's cool
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]
you